i'm convinced that the parallels between
comedians
and politicians are sky high and i can
describe my day-to-day
life as a candidate which would be
incredibly familiar to you it's one
reason why i
like comedians and get on well with many
um of your colleagues i feel like you
get america you get people
like a different way than other folks
because like you've seen so much of the
country
you've been in front of crowds of like
completely different types of people in
different
places at night they just come to have a
good time
yeah i mean i always make this joke that
people call me on social media
a coastal elite just because i live on a
coast and i'm better than other people
and and then i but i point out like i'm
not a co i'm quintessentially not a
coastal elite how many people do you
know have
lived and you know performed and worked
in 45
states for god's sakes like i've i've
seen the whole country i'm not
i'm not uh i'm not cut off from people's
lives no you you can't be and even your
description of what for you is like a
fairly normal gig is like hey
i'm gonna drive to buffalo now i'm gonna
stop in ithaca get my like pizza
fix on the way and then drive another
three hours and then perform in buffalo
and then
stay overnight in buffalo and then maybe
do another like you know i mean that's
like just
normal stuff at least in good times um
and for me running for president
it was wild mike because there were a
few different things i was trying to
make happen at once
but a lot of it revolved around whether
i could get people in iowa new hampshire
behind me and so i would be in iowa new
hampshire and anyone who would have me
i would be there it'd be like hey you
know we're having like a backward
barbecue there
like hey i'm like i would just show up
and
and then i would you know talk about uh
like automation
and my vision and the rest of it um and
it it was
i think very similar to what uh
performers or comedians would do is
where you go to a small town there's a
small crowd and like you kind of work
your way up
um and and so i had to work my way up in
those environments
uh and i used to tell people and this
was more or less true i was like one
iowan or one new hampshire
um voter uh was like worth like a
thousand
californians was my joke that's very
funny yeah
yes and it is it's pretty close
yeah it was pretty accurate um so if i
went to an iowa backyard barbecue and
there are six people there i'd be like 6
000 californians
yeah no i mean my experience of driving
through the country
over the years i mean i've been on the
road for 20 years you know like i i
started
at 22 driving around the country my
mom's beat up volvo station wagon i put
about a hundred
something thousand miles on that car and
uh
my experience has been like i when trump
came along
i was not surprised that his message
of american carnage and all that stuff
was resonating
because i was i was seeing the country
and going like this country's really
struggling
so he's speaking to a thing the problem
is
the way that a snake oil salesman does
he was selling a thing that doesn't fix
the problem
yeah i had the same experience running a
non-profit
i started called venture for america not
as broadly as you where i didn't go to
45 states but i
went to maybe 18 states including
alabama louisiana missouri
ohio michigan and i saw the struggles um
and it's one reason why i became
convinced that we needed to think bigger
about what an economic solution could
look like
and especially when you looked at the
towns that had gotten completely blasted
by
the decimation of manufacturing jobs
like you go there
and so like i'm a serial entrepreneur
and i was running an entrepreneurship
organization
and entrepreneurs are generally very can
do and positive so you're like hey you
know let's do something and start
businesses it's like
make something positive happen and you'd
go to a depressed area in the midwest
and the south and you would just feel
like
like like hey whatever i was going to
say like
i should probably rethink it for this
particular group and environment
totally absolutely being a road comedian
over the years
seeing the country has actually been
great as an artist
because it's forced me similar to what
you're saying it's forced me to
focus on what's human about what i'm
saying instead of what's referential
what's a cultural reference
that might play in new york you know
they always say like
you know new york comedians will show up
places sometimes if they're too insular
and they'll talk about the subway for 20
minutes and people are like i don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
and it is good to sort of see the
country and and understand like
what people's lives are like yeah
completely
and that that was what drove me
um i'm convinced that eventually a
comedian is going to run for office very
very successfully
um so i don't know if it's going to be
you mike i don't know it's going to be
someone else i don't think i have a
thick enough skin
you folks take such a hit
in this way that's so personal i find
they take such personal shots at you and
i feel like it's so unfair
well i guess you would understand it
better than most uh you know as someone
who
puts yourself out there all the time
certainly
i do feel a lot of respect for folks who
run for office because they do take a
lot of shots i think it is
worse for women uh you know i think yeah
for sure
it's worse for um people of color or
pretty much any marginalized group
um but yeah it's it's rough and like
because you're running for office people
have a license to
uh say whatever they want to love about
you more or less
that you you you're you know you have to
uh
um take it in stride i was just gonna
make a sports reference that if you had
like a number one draft pick
sure for comedian as political figure
like someone who could like run for us
said it
and for people think about this like al
franken
yeah uh did it out of minnesota like he
was snl comedian
very very smart uh you know like served
as a senator for a long time
so this to me is more or less inevitable
that there's going to be a high level
yes i think you're right
i think you're right i think that john i
think like john mulaney or dave
chappelle or
ali wong could run and just just
by virtue of their pure skill with
people
would have a ton of traction right out
of the gate so certainly dave
that's for sure certainly dave um john
mullaney
makes sense to me um ali wong
also makes sense to me i hadn't thought
of her but that's a great great
suggestion
yeah now i guess those can be the no the
top three draft picks
i mean i mean you put you could put me
in the mix at one point when trump was
when trump was first elected in 16 we
my wife and i were in such a spiral of
like
what the hell is gonna happen to the
country that i literally said
i may have to run for public office and
i and it wasn't
out of any sense of i wanted to it was
it wasn't everybody's sense of desire no
it was completely
obligation it was simply like someone
has to do
something this is a debacle and that's
when i actually started doing this whole
thing called
i started doing a tour called stand up
and vote and we go to colleges
and we put on essentially free shows we
give the proceeds to
head count and rock the vote and
vote.org
and it was like you know we've had you
know john legend and we've had roy wood
jr and we've
in john stewart did one of them he came
to princeton with us and
you know we've had like all these great
people we're gonna do it again in 22
we're going to do it again in 24. i mean
like
i mean i think voting
i think one of the upsides of this
election in 20
is the voter participation being so high
and then i think that one of the things
that's scary is how many votes trump got
it's awesome you got activated mike i
mean i felt the same way like i never
would have run for president if trump
hadn't won in 16.
um and you and i were in touch uh around
trying to activate voters in georgia
like when we're trying to flip the
senate and
you know you're trying to activate young
people um so
it's awesome that you've driven so much
energy
um to voting among young people who we
all know don't vote at the same levels
as
uh we we'd like in a lot of cases if
dave ran for
like ohio senate he'd probably win that
thing
i think i think he'd win for sure yeah
no i agree with you about chappelle in
ohio i mean i feel like
that would be open and shut case i think
he could run for anything in ohio
because he's lived there for 20 plus
years i he you know dave is the first
guy ever i ever opened for at the
washington dc improv
really yeah so you were a georgetown
student did you just like show up and
do do an improv because dad has deep
roots in dc obviously yep so i
i i i uh my freshman year i showed up at
georgetown
uh and i i had i'd wanted to go to
harvard
because it to follow in the footsteps of
like conan o'brien
like i always thought like that's you go
to the heart you write for the harvard
lampoon
and i thought and then i got and you
know and then i got rejected from
harvard
i actually had a ridiculous interview
for harvard
where the woman who was interviewing me
goes like why would you why do you want
to go to harvard and i go
i want to write for the harvard lampoon
and i pull out
a binder of comedy writing i had
developed over four years this would
either be a home run
or a total strikeout depending upon the
interviewer
she was a she was a lawyer she had
no interest in humor whatsoever
she and then and then this is put the
nails in the coffin she goes uh
is there any other reason you want to go
to harvard other than to write for the
harvard lampoon
and i said uh no that's the main reason
and
and so and clearly it's a huge mistake
it's a huge tactical error
but it was honest you had passion you
had direction
you had a clear vision i love it except
this young man
um like that's where i would have gone
but then i went to georgetown and i was
i auditioned for the improv group i got
in
i i spent four years with those guys
including like nick kroll who i i cast
in the improv group and
he cast john mullaney so there was like
a lineage of
jack and jaclyn novak too so there's
like a really bunch
good bunch of comedians who came out of
there and before me jim gaffigan went to
georgetown
so there's a whole wow you had like this
whole um
like chain of uh yeah town comedians
that kind of
trained each other came up together
there's a yeah and actually jim and i
were talking the other day because we
last year john and jim and i
did we raised a mil believe it or not we
raised a million dollars
for the georgetown scholarship program
which is for first generation college
students
good for you and and we're doing it
again god willing
in the fall and so jim and i were
conspiring about that the other day so
anyway i
i i entered the funniest person on
campus contest at georgetown as a
sophomore
and i won in one of the prizes was to
perform at the dc
improv and they showed me who was coming
soon and i looked i saw dave chappelle's
coming and it was
this is before you know this is around
robin hood men in tights you know i mean
it wasn't like he
had he wasn't chappelle show yet yeah
yes and i was like
but i love dave chappelle and i opened
for him he was so nice
and he's you know i find him to be one
of the nicest people i've encountered in
[Music]
comedy
[Music]
you